هل تعتقد أنه سيكون من الآمن في
نوفمبر أن يذهب الناخبون فعليًا للتصويت
في الاستطلاع ، آمل لذلك لا
يمكنني ضمان ذلك ، أعتقد أنه إذا كان لدينا
طريقة جيدة مدروسة للانطلاق في هذه
الخطوات نحو الحياة الطبيعية التي نأمل بها
في الوقت الذي نصل فيه إلى تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) ،
سنكون قادرين على القيام بذلك
بطريقة قياسية ومع ذلك ، ولا أريد أن
أكون شخصًا متشائمًا ، فهناك
دائمًا احتمال لأننا نصل
إلى الخريف القادم و  في
بداية فصل الشتاء يمكننا أن نشهد
انتعاشًا ونأمل أن يكون ما مررنا به
الآن والقدرة التي
نمتلكها للحصول على قدرة اختبار أفضل
بكثير وقدرة أفضل على
المراقبة والقدرة
على الاستجابة بالإجراءات المضادة مع
الأدوية التي تعمل  ستكون
لعبة كرة مختلفة تمامًا ،
لذا آمل ألا يكون لدينا انتعاش من
شأنه أن يجعل هذا الأمر صعبًا للغاية مع وصولنا
إلى نوفمبر ، ولكن إذا فعلنا ذلك ،
وهناك بالتأكيد احتمال أن أكون واقعيًا ،
فمن المؤكد أن هذا أمر صعب.
نأمل أن نكون قادرين على الاستجابة لهذا الارتداد
بطريقة أكثر فاعلية مما
رأيناه الآن في يناير فبراير مارس